if you've ever read the Harry Potter
books you're probably flattered gasps
stood by the amount of detail JK Rowling
put into the characters physical
appearances and personalities because of
the level of detail the casting crew of
the Harry Potter movies had their work
cut out for them from air styles to
specific traits to body type the casting
directors had to find the perfect match
to play the witches and wizards on the
big screen the actors and actresses of
the Harry Potter movies sometimes match
to the book spot-on
whereas other times they miss to the
market completely first up in the
scarlet and gold Gryffindor House is
Ginny Weasley in the books she's
described as having a fiery and
vivacious personality which body Wright
didn't fully capture Bonnie was often
timid shy soft-spoken and awkward in the
movies especially around Harry in the
books the Ginny was the most vibrant and
energetic around her friends one of
which was Harry Ginny was also described
in the books as having bold and long red
hair bright brown eyes and a face full
of freckles bodies hair is closer to
brown than red and she didn't have a
freckle in sight unfortunately Bonnie
didn't completely capture Ginny's
exciting essence from the novel's next
up is one of Gryffindor's most
intelligent members Hermione Granger in
the books she's described as having
bushy thick hair and buck front teeth
Hermione's big teeth are quite humorous
given that her parents are dentists to
muggles although in the chamber of
secrets
Hermione's teeth become reduced in size
because of a spell Draco Malfoy casts on
her Emma Watson's hair was big and bushy
in the beginning but as the movies
progressed it becomes softer silkier and
flatter Emma also didn't have buck teeth
at any point in the movies in the books
most readers would consider her my need
to be nerdier and perhaps not as
gorgeous as Emma that being said one
thing Emma captured quite well in the
movies was the witty and clever nature
of Hermione Granger before Albus
Dumbledore was the headmaster at
Hogwarts
he was sorted into the Gryffindor House
when he attended the school
Dumbledore is described as having sharp
blue eyes a long crooked nose from being
broken on a few occasions a silver beard
and wearing
Halfmoon glasses he's also described as
having a captivating presence similarly
to an influential visionary Dumbledore
was played by two actors Richard Harris
and Michael Gambon
Richard absolutely captured Dumbledore's
description from the books the only
thing that was off was his beard was
more white than silver
Michael missed the mark a little on the
personality aspects as he was often
stressful to be around and powerful in a
negative way for example in the Goblet
of Fire he was rather harsh on Harry
during the Triwizard Tournament instead
of being hopeful and supportive he also
didn't wear the half moon glasses like
Richard did many members of the Weasley
family are sorted into the Gryffindor
House Ronald is no exception perhaps
it's the wicked red hair that plays a
part only the sorting out would know for
sure
Ron is described in the books as having
the Weasley red hair a long nose a face
full of freckles and a lanky frame with
disproportionate hands and feet Rupert
Grint definitely had the red hair down
pack but his nose was wider and he
wasn't super lean throughout the movies
Rupert filled out and became more
muscular and big which was unlike Ron in
the books however it'd be impossible for
the cast and crew to know exactly what
the actors and actresses would look like
in the future especially since they were
casting quite young another trusty
member of the Gryffindor Houses Neville
Longbottom Neville is described as
having blond hair a round face and stout
figure unfortunately Matthew Lewis
didn't have blond hair or a round face
instead he had brown hair and an oval
face at the start of the movies
Matthew was stout and short but as many
fans know puberty hit him well as he
grew up to be taller and leaner although
how could the casting directors possibly
know that Matthew would look so much
different with age while Matthew may not
have captured the physical descriptions
of Neville he did capture the anxious
shy brave and klutzy personality of
Neville exceptionally well this was true
in the first movie when he stood up to
Harry Hermione and Ron for leaving the
corridors late at night and it was true
in the last movie when he helped Harry
defeat the Dark Lord the most important
character in Harry Potter is well Barry
Potter in the books Harry has green eyes
he's petite and skinny and has
disgruntled jet black hair oh and he has
a thin lightning shape to scar
forehead which is one of the few things
the insecure boy liked about himself in
the beginning Daniel Radcliff captured
the skinny figure of Harry Potter but he
had blue eyes and neat brown hair many
fans would have liked to see the
brilliant green eyes of Harry as they
mimicked his mother's eyes which is an
important aspect of the story but of
course this color is the rarest in
people enough heads but I really don't
care Harry did a good job of capturing
the courageous character and he grew
more confident as the movies went on
just like Harry did in the books
although some of these characters looked
much different from the books there are
some characters who couldn't have been
more accurately casted a great example
of this is Dean Thomas Dean is one of
the secondary characters recurring in
the books the books describe Dean as
having dark hair and dark skin and it
was apparent that he was of African
descent he was also very tall and had a
notably long neck Dean had a tough
upbringing which made him both tolerant
and open-minded Alfred Enoch absolutely
embodied the physical characteristics of
Dean he was even taller than Ron which
was a distinction made in the books
alfred also did a great job of
demonstrating Dean's personality as he
was open to new ideas saying could
handle a lot of pressure every great
story needs some comic relief and that's
precisely what Fred and George Weasley
contributed to the story in the books
fred is the more energetic sarcastic and
bull twin whereas George is the humble
reserved in quiet humor twin the
identical twins are described as having
the trademark red Weasley hair and a
stocky build in the movies James and
Oliver Phelps are tall and lanky which
was a discrepancy however they did an
amazing job of providing comic relief to
the story and embodied Fred and George's
personalities it must be hard to cast
twins in a movie with that in mind the
cast and crew did an excellent job the
eldest child of the big Weasley family
is Bill Weasley bill isn't a big
character in the books until much later
as he's already finished to school at
Hogwarts when Ron begins his education
when he makes his appearance bill is
described as having red hair and long
scars and disfigurations on his face as
a result of a nasty fight with friend
rear Greyback domhnall gleeson looked
much like a Weasley but the scars on his
face were tame in comparison to the
books
option many would have appreciated more
gruesome scars as that would better
capture the divided state and aggression
of the Wizarding World another member of
the Hogwarts and Gryffindor House alumni
is Remus Lupin Remus is a werewolf which
has caused difficulties in his life
which is why he's described as having
great flecks in his hair despite his
young age a sickly and exhausted
appearance and worn-out clothes after
all who wouldn't look a little
distraught after running through the
woods all night howling David Thewlis
did a great job of embodying the
tiresome appearance of Remus but his
wardrobe and hair weren't on par in the
movies this is unfortunate as it would
have been an easy fix to put some gray
hair dye in David's hair and make some
tears in his clothes some might have
been shocked by the fact that Sirius
Black was a member of the Gryffindor
House back in the day Sirius is
reputation as a prisoner of azkaban
definitely preceded him his appearance
got the better of him too as he was
described in the books as being bony
skeleton like and crazed looking due to
his hard life he also had dirty long
hair that fell to his elbows sunken eyes
oily skin and yellow teeth in the books
Sirius is definitely one scary-looking
guy but he had good intentions to help
Harry as he was an old friend of Harry's
father James Gary Oldman captured the
appearance quite well but was lacking
other aspects of Sirius as sickly
appearance he also lacked of the long
hair and skeletal look before Minerva
McGonagall was a professor at Hogwarts
she attended the school and was sorted
into the Gryffindor House Minerva is
described as having black hair that she
rarely let down and was intense looking
she often looked prim and pursed her
lips occasionally she would let loose
whereby she appeared to be an entirely
different person Maggie Smith did an
amazing job of capturing Minerva's
appearance and personality although she
was described as younger looking in the
books compared to the movies one detail
they forgot to include was Minerva
square spectacles Minerva often wore
these glasses to match the markings of
her animagus and Patronus which was a
silver tabby cat this is a minor detail
otherwise the cast and crew did an
excellent job Seamus Finnigan is one of
Harry Potter's quirkier characters and a
member of the Gryffindor House
in the books Seamus is described as
having an Irish accent sandy colored
hair and a sloppy appearance he also has
an impeccable knack for making things
explode by a mistake
Devin Murray did a good job with the
Irish accent and sloppy clothes in the
movie he's often blowing things up by
mistake in the movies leaving his face
covered in black residue and his hair
spiky and burnt the one thing Devin was
missing was the sandy hair but otherwise
he was spot-on
in the Goblet of Fire Harry takes
Parvati Patil to the Yule Ball which is
one of the first moments we really
noticed this Gryffindor House character
poverty is described as having long
black hair that is often braided and she
has a pretty appearance she's also known
for being into fashion and gossip
similarly to her good friend lavendar
brown chef Ollie Chaudhary is gorgeous
however her long hair was rarely braided
in the movies instead it was often worn
in a half ponytail chef Ollie did an
excellent job of playing the giggly and
Smyly character of Parvati she was also
witty and easygoing like poverty was in
the books last but not least we have the
cute innocent Colin Creevey Colin is one
of the younger characters in the books
and he sorted into Gryffindor house it's
implied that he looks up to Harry like a
hero and he's often described as being
overly excitable he is also petite and
has mousy brown hair Hugh Mitchell did a
superb job of embodying the cheerfulness
and high energy of Colin he also looked
very much like Colin in the movies the
cast and crew did an excellent job with
him even though he wasn't a main
character JK Rowling is known for being
a descriptive and imaginative writer in
the Harry Potter novels while this is
exceptional for a reader you can
probably understand how it would be a
challenge for casting directors to get
every little detail from the books onto
the big screen and for more videos about
Harry Potter and fandoms subscribe to
the things we'll catch you next time